light flexible and strong carbon fibers
are being billed as a revolutionary
alternative to the steel skeleton which
gives reinforced concrete its stability
Munford kuiba is a civil engineer he and
his team at Dresden's Technical
University have developed so-called
textile concrete
they've been comparing its performance
to steel concrete so far the results
have been promising
that's oskins material food EBV carbon
fibers are basically too soft to be able
to add them directly to concrete this is
so completed is being Vandy optics
machine and so after they've been woven
together they're given a coating to
stiffen a zine so that's the I think mr.
steiffel type equipment and the fibers
in the weave are adjusted for maximum 10
sylheti so they'll perform optimally in
the concrete or kumara abide light these
individual fibers form the basis of the
concrete up to 50,000 of them are
combined to form a yarn it's then
processed on an automated loom to
produce woven mesh
the new concrete's textile interior
emerges from a myriad of fine threads
next the researchers add another coat to
the mesh that increases stability
fifteen minutes later the piece is cut
to length concrete is a mixture of
cement sand and water a special mixture
is created containing very finely ground
cement as well as other ingredients this
fine mixture is used to produce thin
sheets of textile concrete the sheets
are much lighter and more robust than
standard reinforced concrete
first the millimeter thin layer of fine
concrete is transferred to a form spread
evenly and finished the carbon mesh is
then added and encased in a further thin
layer of concrete finally the finished
sheet of textile concrete has to harden
for 24 hours like that axial concrete
costs less in terms of material and
energy so making it produces fewer
emissions co2 IOT's the big question is
how much force can the concrete
withstand such tests need to be carried
out in a lab architects and surveyors
need this information when they're
planning projects the scientists
increase the load on a girder until it
reaches its breaking point
the first Crocs appear but the carbon
material inside can withstand immense
force the test shows the textile
concrete is six times more robust than
conventional reinforced concrete but
even if the new material does boast
impressive characteristics it's not
indestructible
a to the SP Blucher to get approval for
constructing the first bridge made of
textile concrete we had to load a test
version to breaking point so that the
authorities could see what it would bear
that's five master words we repaired the
test bridge provisionally and we now
exhibited here yellow stood the insights
garnered from the tests have enabled the
scientists to turn their attention to
other models they say carbon fibers
offer enormous potential
Aelita victorian material Desmond's will
be concrete as clunky and heavy una
Litton and not really suitable for
living Russia with the smart money human
Ken Burns Mountain our duty for a new
from Kabul but the use of carbon means
that we can now create quite slim
components like chairs arm chairs and
tables no cushion textile concrete looks
set to give engineers and designers a
completely new tool to express their
ideas
who knows what masterpieces will be
created in the future from this
versatile yet extremely robust material